des principes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a deux familles ce soir qui vont
s'affronter quand une famille qui est
devenu une légende
la famille morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
isabelle avec leurs familles
représentées nous votre famille isabelle
alors mon conjoint web votre conjoint
dressage non les gars comme merci anne
roumanoff six nations
[Applaudissements]
votre fils mon fils et françois et je
prends soin il est extrêmement
sympathique vous à travailler à rtl et
isabelle morini-bosc exactement depuis
17 ans oui et c'est ça qui vous avez
fait perdre vos cheveux
la famille morin représenter mon fils
chéri bastien sébastien vous allez être
roux ça ne va pas échapper quoi parce
que même mon fils était rouen naissant
et puis après l'asie nos bras ont mis
plus à rien mais j'allais lui faire un
petit bisou à pic
[Applaudissements]
comme disait mon grand père mais pour
être plusieurs sur une bonne affaire
tout seul sur une mauvaise
sébastien vous êtes professeur d eps et
vous vous êtes prof de badminton se sent
tout à fait de penne 2 ps allez on y va
alors isabelle voterait nous tiens
isabelle ce que vous êtes tous les
championnats de badminton avec les hauts
talons nude en deuil mais rien et le
probable monteront à donner sur la
débâcle
vous avez vous ils sont courts mais sans
rigoler c'est pas très bonnes et si vous
mettez là ils vont jouer comme ça vous
allez aller ou sur votre mère ben ouais
bah oui oui d'arrêter la jolie et jovial
à sébastien que vous en pensez sébastien
je dirais qui tu appelles je voulais
montrer très bien mais le vieux là bah
ouais sébastien venez venez montrer un
peu je montrais quand je d'accord alors
c'est simple prenez votre comme ça vous
êtes le volant assez d'accord oui moi
entrer
[Applaudissements]
honnêtement je pense qu'il a plus de
chances aux tripotages fait dans le
badminton
[Applaudissements]
allez allez merci le shérif merci en
première mi temps
oui bah calmez-vous il a dit martin un
partout c'est vraiment bah oui j'ai un
petit doute comme en bas boyer moi aussi
parce que j'ai senti comme parties
s'étaient pas précisément de badminton
apparemment son portable a dit brees
marie claire et il appelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est c'est la première manche marie
kerque comment ça va marquer votre fils
il a une fiancée ou pas non il n'a pas
tout bien fait mais il a toujours été
attiré par il a déjà été tiré par les
femmes
vous aimez danser danser le zouk le zouk
l'allée des vêtements bijoux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces gens là
[Musique]
m
c'est bon vous avez senti quelque chose
vous l'avez bien constituer des signaux
et ça mais je suis le seul à avoir vu
bon parce que excuse moi enfin je te
connais pas du tout se désole cyril d'un
ton mais la prochaine fois ça t'évite
d'accord dans le coup et c'est peut-être
le seul à l'avoir vu le bisou bons coups
c'est quoi c'est un non sens
bisous ta bouche son coût de la mer et
la langue
cette émission c'est une ambition mais
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] son habitation
enfin c'est ma mère ni seriez pas pardon
désolé c'est réussi et oscar sébastien
la famille morges et nyon ceux qui voici
la question mettez votre marque derrière
le dos à quoi d'autre peut penser une
femme pendant l'amour à la liste de
courses
[Rires]
la liste non non mike l'air d'aller à
vampire mon panier empire votre animé
oui en fait cette année mais on a
maintenant marley à un autre homme à une
autre personne tu démarres bien dans la
vie alors oui les frais de la main qui
fait l'âme américain pouvait y aller
perso je n'ai déjà ton de connaissance
de la vie sociale est-ce que vous avez
déjà pensé à isabelle en faisant l'amour
honnêtement oui on est tombé j'aurais
aimé que ce soit ça soit le cas
d'isabelle mais oui je sais pas le monde
deux fois mais c'est vrai que je suis
très sur les femmes les femmes matures
j'aime les célébrités en jeu derrière
moi je pense sa célébrité quand je fais
la moue mais si je puis me permettre
oui il a dû entendre c'est dans les
vieux pots qu'on fait les bonnes soupes
et jif tous ont dit c'est pas avec des
carottes nouvelles
yogo je me sens pas bien si tout va bien
tout va bien tout va bien bas la croix
pour moi pardon mais si j'étais
complètement perdue mais j'allais dire
un roux mais quand même pas je pense
pouvait penser à moi quand j'y vais mais
je te cherche à les améliorer pour faire
son mari à son mari moi j'essaie de
sauver les meubles
allez la famille marzolini vous auriez
dit qu à jouir sébastien chabal par
exemple encore isabelle battre
à l'évidence à isabelle il vous plait
sébastien si vous étiez pas de cadeau il
est très bien fait de sa personne ça
c'est sûr ah oui
de face et de fait ce rien à redire à ça
va vous trouvez ça oui tout à fait
acceptable mais n'emploiera quand même
serré pour mon pool de bâle à brig est
tombée est-ce que vraiment qu'ils ne se
sentent plus est ce que vraiment
vraiment je vous intéresse c'est chaud
donc si tu peux sébastien c'est une base
où vous aimez vraiment non c'est pas une
bonne sincèrement c'est vrai que ça
m'est arrivé de penser à isabelle en
voilà moi c'est vrai oui à lui refaire
un derby ça va oui ça n'est pas facile
[Applaudissements]
mais attendez l'émission rejouer c'est
mon plein et fiona les sages étaient pas
élevé comme ça je me place est un peu
d'ambition des pays acp chargée
d'apprécier si j'ose dire allez je vais
demander à la venir me voir et à ses
lectrices
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ayrault sur l'amour et la paix sébastien
et alain non mais je risque pas de le
taper bon donc je tape à la bouche avec
la bouche ouais enfin ça va peut-être
manqué par espèce parce que vous avez un
certain âge que voilà on peut se parler
on a craqué c'est toi qui m'a traité de
vieux tout à l'heure c'était pas méchant
c'est non alors vous avez dû vous je
suis pour rien fait rien c'est pas dieu
soit est mort de sa belle mort du tout
il faudra gay comme ça sur un plateau
excusez moi mais je trouve ça il est
amoureux d'isabelle regard des toits non
mais oh moi je sors d'où tout le très
bon même allez on arrête aller à la
selle doit optimiser
je pense que non vraiment il n'ya pas de
bijoux ce n'est pas du tout attention
deux mains derrière le dos voici la
question compléter cette expression
chaud comme à zhouqu chaud comme un zoom
zoom
[Musique]
d'ailleurs elle il était sur le doubs il
était très chaud ici on a vu ça à
isabelle venez faire un petit bisou et
sébastien allais ça suffit à les
comparer tout jamais parlé vous parlez
vous en d'autres temps en d'autres temps
franchement j'aurais pas dit non
oui
c'est comme un doudou crois pas trop
alors je chante comme la braise chaud
comme la braise
ouais
[Applaudissements]
oh non qu'est-ce que la scala
alors venir n'est trouvé ça choquant ce
qui se passera lors les séries eaux se
calment à laon c'est qu'elle n'aime pas
l'eau c'est juste alain que vous avez
été piégé pour la grande race rare
mercialys
[Applaudissements]
il est rare qu'il a dédié toute votre
famille tout le monde est au courant et
peut lui faire un gros bisou fans
[Applaudissements]
au choix
[Musique]